Wow, you did a Latin version point two.
There's a lot on this screen,
it's looking pretty slick.
>> Well it wasn't just me,
we've been hard at work.
>> Do you want to look at the y frames?
>> Yeah sure,
let's review what we've done.
In version zero point two the app,
you made the fundamental screens
of shopping list plus plus.
This included the main screen with all
the lists, also known as the shopping
lists fragment, and
the shopping list detail screen,
also known as the active
list details activity.
In order to do this, you needed to
master reading and writing data.
You also learned about
the FirebaseUI library,
which helps you easily show up to
date Firebase data in the list view.
At this point, you've got an app that
can be edited by a bunch of users
simultaneously, which can add lists,
rename them, and delete them.
Inside of those lists, we've also
got items that any user can add.
And on your own, I'm going to
have you work on the edit and
delete functionality for those items.
>> If your users work well together,
I'd say this is a pretty useful app.
>> Well, JP,
that's actually why you're here.
Take a look.
>> Wow, do humans even eat those?
>> I don't know.
It seems that we have a troll in our
midst.
>> Well,
have you considered another option?
Maybe something from outside
your group of roommates?
Anyone who told them to?
>> But I hadn't shared
the code with anyone, unless.
You.
Who have you been talking to?
You're under a non-disclosure agreement.
Was it Grocery Grabber?
How much did they pay you?
How much?
>> You know,
another way to solve this is to
implement user authentication Firebase.
With user authentication, you can share
accounts, you can create lists and
add items to lists.
>> Interesting.
That's actually not a bad idea.
>> Yeah and Firebase user
authentication is really pretty easy.
>> Well, I better read up
on user authentication, but
I'll see you both in version
point three of the app.